ce sont des hommes qui cherchent un
avenir meilleur
qui veulent à tout prix
la voix
on a vu cet automne des images
déchirantes alors que la caravane
d'immigrants aux états unis a provoqué
une crise politique et humanitaire
l'autre les campings et ceux des hits us
compris ils sont encore nombreux à
courir de grands risques pour venir
chine
ils cherchent des alternatives et
risquer leur vie c'est l'une d'elles
l'an dernier notre équipe a suivi une
famille de congolais sur la route de
tous les dangers
j'ai laissé tout
j'aime avant ce sens vient amener je
n'ai rien l'artiste brésil ils ont
réussi à entrer au canada après un
parcours parfois terrifiant c'est pour
vous très souvent je ne peux jamais
conseillé aperçoit ce soir on vous
montre la nouvelle vie de rosette et ses
proches
après une première année au canada ici
et à la liberté bon j'ai vu l'expression
bienvenue à enquête
[Musique]
oh
chaque jour les milliers de personnes
prennent des routes souvent dangereuses
pour fuir leur pays
c'est les pelouses un déplacement de
population depuis la deuxième guerre
mondiale aux immigrés aux nouveaux
risques et la mort sur la route que de
l'attendre la leyre pays ravagé par la
pauvreté la violence les guerres et les
catastrophes naturelles
mais les push emplit les pays
réaffirment leur porte mine celle qui
permettait d'accéder au rêve américain
oui en gohelle et we don't want m
[Applaudissements]
mary l'arrêt de l'immigration
ce sont vos dirigeants qui encouragent
et mono président à me faire souffrir
ses concerne aussi dit non on va chez
vous alors cette fois ci bas state of
mind the refugees and they were cadre de
ce programme
canada le canada christ est l'un des
rares pays encore perçu comme terre
d'accueil au canada en amérique
c'est là où vivaient seuls les documents
nécessaires pour se déplacer en avion
des milliers de migrants la traversée
onze pays du continent américain à
travers le genre
campagne
[Musique]
ces migrants attendent le canada est
définie réf
les canada dry
la presse canadienne
[Musique]
cela fait plus de six mois qu'on a
commencé à préparer ses
ces voyages ont rêvé d c'est d'aller
dans un pays qui parle français
le canada s'est déjà 42 ans et j'aurai
brossette vient de quitter sao paulo au
brésil
il voyage avec son marigot des andes
réfugié politique à l'ère des mondes
nous avons changé leur nom comporte tous
les migrants qui apparaîtront dans ce
reportage
rochette et godet ont fuit la violence
du congo il voyage avec leur fille
pauline et marie les recracher traverser
le brésil le pérou jusqu'à l'équateur
puis la colombie l'amérique centrale
vers le mexique
les états unis et enfin le canada en
voyage des plus de 20000 km avec une
coup de chance ils arriveront à
destination
à moins de six mois rochette a tout
laissé derrière elle est équipée de sa
foi et de sa bible pour affronter la
route
il sait version ciné fortifie beaucoup
d'indiens je suis je suis tout lien qui
foulera la plante de votre pied
je vous les donne comme je n'ai donné
amour
beaucoup parcours sécurisé
tout au long de nos martyrs et je sais
que l'éternel
j'avais 12 ans j'essaierai toujours
wenger
[Musique]
pour recettes comme des milliers
d'autres africains cuba et haïtiens sans
pour le seul endroit sur les continents
amérique où les routes empruntées par
les migrants convergent
c'est d'ici qu'est partie non pour
ferrer long et pénible voyage vers le
canada ou les états unis
ils sont arrivés au brésil alors que les
pays se préparait à accueillir les
olympiques la coupe du monde de soccer
et d'autres événements internationaux la
construction d'infrastructures leur
permettait de récolter l'argent
nécessaire pour reprendre la route
procès était administratrice des
finances avant de fuir les congo à sao
paulo il nettoyait les toilettes une
hôtel pour faire des économies
conçoit élabore en uniforme ont une
égale et boude
[Musique]
je suis allé le toit les jeux plein jour
ce que vous trouvez comme ça
à nous tous un centre et la flandre lys
à l'eau sauf qu'avoir des jeunes malades
ses qualités du canada bon je me fais je
me préparais que l'épée que j'ai je
connais pas du tout bon je sais que ceux
souffrant comédie qui sont pas faciles
parce qu'on fait des jours à pied c'est
pas quel parcours ont fait déjouer à
pied c'est pas facile quand on est des
îles se pose toujours la question est ce
que ça vaut la peine de mettre ma vie en
danger
mais quand les conditions de vie ne sont
pas dignes ils cherchent des
alternatives
c'est risqué leur vie c'est l'une
d'elles dans sa terre iscar à blida
je décourage les séparaient pourquoi des
risques pareils d'avis tout est dit et
quand vous mourrez c'est fini
or et c'est fini son ensemble où
précisément au brésil
radiomee quand nous sommes là claudine
et animatrice à la radio
elle croit que si les pays ouvraient
leurs portes les migrants ne seraient
pas obligées de risquer leur vie au fond
n'est guère nous voir des tragédies nous
fouillons des gens qui viennent piller
[Musique]
les récentes parties
rien mais décourage français c'est
plaisant malgré les avertissements elle
va partir il croit que sa foi et son
meilleur atout pour affronter la route
avec la prière et le tente de surmonter
sa peur de l'inconnu l'artificier prends
courage à zaventem bois bowman était un
bel ajout souhait la haute volée ratée
pied je serai avec toi aujourd'hui je
profite sans paroles
mais rend cet ego d'aînés voyage spatial
vers le canada huit autres sujets
congolais les accompagnent mais ils ont
peur de montrer leur visage
[Musique]
brochettes et misna prête à faire face à
sa destinée je m'appelle rosette g41
arrivé au canada avec mes deux filles
[Musique]
quito capitale de l'équateur
depuis plus d'une décennie cette ville
est devenue la plaque tournante de la
migration irrégulière vers la médina
bon
les migrants et les réfugiés qui passe
par ici arrivent d'un peu partout
la majorité d'entre eux poursuivent leur
trajet sans passeport les documents de
voyage ils ont tout intérêt à se
déplacer les plus rapidement possible
pour éviter les contrôles migratoires ne
fait pas exception
elle passe en tout 20 d'une gare
d'autobus à l'autre
mais pas si c'est pour les enfants
indépendance et pour les discussions par
les discussions d'autres migrants
doivent s'arrêter à quito pour gagner
leur jeanne désert afin de poursuivre
leur voyage
certains finissent par y rester et ils
ont redonné vie à des quartiers avec les
migrants sont arrivés les passeurs les
coyotes comme on les appelle dans la
région ils ne sont pas trop visible mais
ils sont là selon certains pays il est
des migrants sans papiers à franchir
illégalement les frontières on les
appelle des boîtes
parfois on les appelle des poulets boîte
ou poulet c'est comme ça qu'on appelle
les migrants à la recherche d'un
meilleur avenir
procès et deux de ses passes or in
aimable de groupe qui accompagne les
migrants du sco nord de la colombie
l'épi entre 1800 et 2500 $ par audika ya
plusieurs routes pour éviter les
contrôles dans nos colonnes le savon
wells ans nous savons aussi quelles sont
les meilleures pour se déplacer et par
où il faut passer pour pas avoir de
problème
ce match de ces traversées illégales
font en sorte que personne ne sait avec
certitude combien des migrants en
transit et par quito mais les organismes
humanitaires estiment qu'il y en a eu au
moins nous sa mine depuis quatre ans
[Musique]
quand c'est sa famille les groupes des
congolais honte à thème la ville de tout
cas là sont frontalières des l'équateur
avec la colombie
mais vous avez quand même content
c'est nous avançons
avant même d'arriver à tout le temps
rochette avait déjà vécu sa première
expérience avec un groupe dépassera au
pérou ils ont rentré l'ancien maire de
ce débat
les comptines et rosset une africaine à
ce qu'une documents de voyage doit voir
un nouveau recours aux services des
passeports pour éviter d'attirer
l'attention
la frontière entre l'équateur et la
colombie est poreuse l'absence des
barrages permis aux gens de circuler
librement
mais il faut éviter les gestes suspect
les mouvements tenue n'est pas sûr passe
à l'action
aborder ces taxis brousse est et sa
famille traverse la frontière
clandestinement les rats ni les
attendent déjà
de l'autre côté procède à ou de
l'essence les soirs même les autorités
colombien mise en place un barrage
routier pour effectuer des contrôles
aléatoires
les migrants qui traversent en colombie
sont d'origine des plus ample vallier
n'est pas les miens et anglais dc vitré
et des somaliens ont tous été arrêtés
[Musique]
tout ça me paraît sous sa jupe lui
laisse un papier plus fortunés peuvent
s'offrir un service des passeurs haut de
gamme pour 37 mille dollars
les migrants chinois qui a donné moyens
sont escortés de la chine jusqu'à la
frontière américaine dépasse au andris
se spécialise dans les transports des
migrants chinois sous membres de groupe
formé de personnes de plusieurs pays
notre patron habite un autre continent
chaque groupe et responsable du
transport de migrants dans son propre
pays et l'opérateur colombien ils
travaillent sous les ordres de la mafia
chinoise en chine c'est ce qu'a informé
si un de nos passagers tombe malade
nous devons payer ses frais médicaux ont
jamais comment c'était travail risqué
pour nous et pour notre famille
parce que nos patrons nous surveille
[Musique]
ap les 7000 km rochette et sa famille
arrive à médine au terminal d'autobus
une surprise les attend à hermine et
nous avons passé la nuit au terminal
mais d'impasse nous étions arrivés la
nuit il n'y avait pas moins d'acheter
les billets parce que nous n'avons pas
de laissez-passer pour acheter les
billets pour l'obtenir
ces laissez-passer qui permet de
séjourner temporairement pays rocher
aurait dû se présenter au poste de
frontier de son entrée en colombie mais
aussi plaisante en rangée courait le
risque d'être refoulés
son pays ni si elle conçoit et met dès
le matin et ça a été compliqué parce ne
voit pas dépasser pas il aurait ne
fallait pas nous comprendre qu'on ne
veut pas de documents donc supprimé 9
banc ne vont pas c'est la fin de l'an
par trop recettes et ses compagnons de
voyage après qu'ils se rendraient foulée
c'est pas facile je regrette mais je
n'en sais rien si je vois comment est
mon pays à se développer c'est parfait
je n'ai pas le choix
[Musique]
mais rossi insiste et en voyant notre
caméra les fonctionnaires finissent par
céder
[Musique]
les laissez-passer à mais la famille
c'est didier vers la gare de toulouse
prochaine étape les noms de la colombie
c'est la région bananière du pays le
régime dégage force économique
sur les rives du golfe de là-bas tout
repos une petite ville d'environ nous
sommes mille habitants c'est ici qu'est
l'autoroute panaméricains vers le nord
enfin les prochains tronçon de la route
se fera par voie maritime
au délà et le tampon des aliens les
bouchons tous des liens une jungle
inhospitalière qui sépare la colombie le
panama
derrière les commerces et la prospérité
de tout repos ces caches contre elle
était frappante la tranquillité les
autorités sont menacés par des groupes
criminels transnationaux très puissant
la position géostratégique de la région
favorise le commerce international mais
elle favorise aussi des activités
criminelles comme le passage de drogue
les colonel antonio dingue on combat les
criminels dans ces deux régions
il est très conscients des risques
qu'ils courent les migrants qui se
dirige vers le panama son propos autour
caresse la forme et 9 passes et je pense
qu'il faut trouver une façon de rendre
ces pays viable que le rêve américain
soit celui de vivre dans son propre pays
avec sa culture sa langue et ses
coutumes et avec des opportunités de
travail d'éducation
c'est dans cette région dangereuse
careep le petit goût des réfugiés
congolais rejeté ses amis s'installe
dans une petite pension à touba
ils ont appris qu'ils la frontière avec
le panama est fermé pour les migrants et
qu'il est pas sûr gonfler leur pic n'a
pas au passé normal c'est 30 voire mai
pour laisser des gens là qui est des
gens pour progresser de monde sans ça
c'est un dollar à personne et aussi ce
n'était pas aussi mais nous n'avions pas
encore accepté la pension ses trousses
non loin du port les congolais sont pris
à partie la nuit porte quel moment
sauf qu'il faut atteindre procède combat
les peace man il doit faire preuve
d'imagination pour nourrir sa famille
tout en s'occupant des enfants la plus
grande joie
si jamais ce qui est maison ma femme
voiture pour aller saf à l'école
pour éviter la tente certains migrants
tentent de se glisser parmi les
touristes et la population locale les
pari est risqué
la marine colombienne a intensifié sa
puissance
éviter les contrôles d'autres milan
préfèrent placer leur vie entre elles et
même dépasser les naufrages sont
fréquents à bord de six embarcations
souvent mal entretenus
une mort certaine pour ceux qui n'ont
pas la charge d'être rescapés
[Musique]
au cimetière local les tombes de
migrants non identifié témoin de ces
deux réalités comme catholiques
je fais une prière pour que dieu
pardonne leur péché après tout ils sont
humains la route des migrants c'est ça
aussi l'anonymat
même après la mort de leur vie pour un
sentier il s'efforce à le traverser
parfois ils moi ou quelqu'un est tué
finalement plusieurs se retrouvent ici
mais seul dans le cimetière sans que
personne pleurent leurs morts
la famille qui est loin crois qu'ils
sont arrivés à destination
voilà ils sont ici par à rire très peu
de ces histoires d'horreur en tout non
et d'elvis martinez aguilar est un
compagnon de voyage ont payé très cher
elle rêve d'atteindre le nord
des sons brocas et journaliste il sut
avec un télé les histoires des migrants
c'est ici où on a retrouvé les cadavres
cumin quoi ils sont partis la nuit quand
il était proche du marais le capitaine
du bateau a fait un détour
les cubains ne s'attendait pas à ça les
pins sont alors sorti un pistolet et de
machettes et de couteaux et ils leur ont
dit on va vous volez coach on a retrouvé
les corps ici flottant dans les marais
et d'elvis été violées à plusieurs
épices il a été égorgé son cas
le temps me découper au couteau
l'incident a changé la donne pour les
trafiquants de migrants les 500 ont été
arrêtés et seront accusés de meurtre les
migrants ont peur quand il arrive dans
la région ils demandent s'ils vont être
en sécurité
si quelque chose peut leur arriver ils
ont peur de vivre la même chose que ces
cubains c'est dans ce contexte que sa
famille et leurs amis congolais prennent
le large
quelque part sur la côte à l'abri des
autorités nous partons à
le cherche
après la pause rosette et ces enfants
arrivent à l'étape la plus dangereuse de
leur parcours
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
on reprend la route avec le groupe de
migrants qui se trouvent maintenant la
frontière du panama et la colombie
c'est l'étape la plus dangereuse de leur
parcours parce qu'ils doivent traverser
à pied une jungle qui a été le tombeau
de nombreux migrants
tout récemment 28 personnes dont dix
enfants ont trouvé la mort en tentant de
traverser cette jungle
la navigation sur la mer des caraïbes pu
être périlleuse les embarcations sont
souvent mal entretenus
ce dans les villages des caps il y en a
qui nous finissons par des joints de
rose 7 et son groupe qui ne savent pas
nager se remettaient encore de
l'expérience
je suis un compte en blanc
les plaques ce que j'avais la mort avec
balles et n'a vu encore j'en ai un
projet trop en dire
je n'ai plus rien dans ma vie
avis mouillé
que dieu
[Musique]
chers considère qu'à pau ryanair comme
un paradis sur terre située sur les
rives de la mer des caraïbes
ces villas s'est entourée par la jungle
c'est tout régions pluvieuses coller à
la frontière avec le panama et
mentalement et amauri monterrey des
moines et la porte elle est fermée
afin de poursuivre leur route vers le
nord les migraines doivent traverser les
gens le dieu des liens le panama a
augmenté ses contrôles dans les vues de
refouler les migrants roset et shanghai
vient grossir les rangs des centaines de
migrants qui sont bloqués ici à temps
pour cannes a donc on a quant à elle
signé ligne il nous arrive avec des
enfants et des femmes enceintes
selon edgar mieux ils sont plus de 350
migrants les villages presque 10% de la
population
notre principale préoccupation c'est la
santé des villageois et celle des
migrants
nous sommes quatre mille cinq cents
personnes en tout nous n'avons que
médecins et deux infirmières
ça ne suffit pas on devrait avoir trois
ou quatre médecins
nous n'avons pas il ne devrait pas
passer par ici ça me brise le coeur
désire ça ce sont des êtres humains à la
recherche d'une vie meilleure
difficile pour les migrants décédés
simulé d'un si petit village
nous cherchons tavart des paroles comme
ce n'est pas les retrouver sur les bords
de la mer il n'attend qu'une seule chose
départ de la route
procède s'accroche à l'espoir que du
panama ou bleu bientôt sa frontière
d'autres comme nicolas aux migrants
haïtiens ont décidé de tenter leur
chance
après avoir embauché un passeur et
parcouru les dangers les sentiers qui
sillonnent la jungle nicolas elle sa
famille de trois enfants ont été
refoulés je fais trois jours trois ou
quatre jours marcher dans les faux vert
et trois nuits on peut dors dans les
forêts est magique et les frontières
fermées à la police m'a retourné
enregistre ici à car pour dana shaw
payer aux propos puis descendent au
large sont mâchés dans le solaire pour
arriver sur le summum c'est mon agent a
prédit aussi
c'est mon agent en attendant qui sait
contrôle lâche nicolas des charges des
bateaux pour mieux sa famille je vais
chercher quelque chose pour matri
madelon famille je vais acheter 0 ou de
poisson c'est pour en forme en ce moment
mon enfant on a le majeur et j'espère y
six coups ou solutionner ce canal
ouvriers de frontières
je vais continuer au moins jusqu'à
l'hiver analystes
[Musique]
ces histoires finissent par des collages
et recettes
l'acca se prolonge mais la vie est trop
chère ici on va retourner un tour en
attendant quand on va ouvrir leurs
portes et nous allons continuer le
chemin pour moi je voulais qu'on avance
qu'on est en avant mais malheureusement
comme le fautif on n'entend rien nous
allons attendre
ceux-ci réception pour moi brochet
n'abandonne pas pour autant chez les
culs mais qui est un peu l'air je ne
peux pas abandonner j'avais mon idée
vous élever mon niveau et est d'arriver
jusqu'au bout non à mon objectif et même
après 1,2 moi j'arrivais toujours
j'ai l'espoir et la foi non j'étais
touché inquiète elle a impliqué le
chemin qui traverse la jungle est
surnommée la route de la mort dans la
jungle
ils vivent de mauvais moments les
montées et descentes sont difficiles
plusieurs meurent sur le chemin d'un
infarctus de blessures ou de morsures
ou découvrir ces qui attend brossé
lorsqu'il reprendra son chemin vers le
canada nous avons décidé de nous
aventurer sur l'un des nombreux sentiers
des légendes du des liens les guides
touristiques ou berthod est dépassé et
or nous accompagneront ces derniers à
excideuil l'anonymat dehors je suis un
paysan est un multi qui travaille sur la
montagne les migrants passés je les
retrouvais souvent perdus dans la jungle
j'ai commencé par les aider à se rendre
au sommet de la montagne et maintenant
je le fais à plein temps
[Musique]
les migrants partout beau milieu de la
nuit selimi jour moment pour des durées
les autorités pour assurer notre
sécurité
il a fallu obtenir la permission du club
de golf la mafia locale qui contrôle ce
territoire
la traversée de la jungle peut prendre
des trois à six jours ou plus encore
tout dépend des conditions des sentiers
et des passeurs normal son marchand un
bon rythme on va arriver à la frontière
dans guitar là un endroit pour dormir ou
normalement les gens quand s'en passera
impossible de savoir comment ni peur ou
se diriger
[Musique]
c'est un saut dans l'inconnu l'avis du
que nous paie théâtre et les mêmes de
notre guide et de passeur on vient de
franchir la première étape souvent les
migrants sont très fatigués et on
s'arrête une demi heure avant il faut
que les migrants monte encore trois
étapes de plus pour atteindre le sommet
de la montagne
plus les journées à 20 h plus la chaleur
et l'humidité sont insupportables les
long des sentiers d'événements abandonné
et des restes d'emballage laissés par
les migrants
au cas où les personnes à qui sont
directement à mes yeux ne sait vraiment
si les gens ne se sentent pas bien il
faut les attendre et des guides qui
impose un rythme effréné aux migrants
ils sont irresponsables
les passeurs doivent être sur le qui
vive pour les animaux sauvages qui
pourrait surprendre les migrants et les
scorpions et serpents venimeux qui se
cache le long des sentiers
progressivement les décrire des
difficultés augmentent les pactes des
liens de plus en plus incliné la pluie
des derniers jours par les ascensions
difficiles
c'est une personne sur true faut y aller
doucement se reposer chaque 10 minutes
et s'asseoir avec eux si on ne fait pas
des gens peuvent mourir à cause de
l'effort les morts reste sur les routes
ce sont les paysans qui attire les
cadavres les long des sentiers
la frontière avec le panama est encore
loin les migrants qui atteignent la
frontière du panama c'est et saufs
ça c'est fait le prendre par des
patrouilles et sont soulagés ils sont
soulevés qu à la section la plus
dangereuse des la jambe n'est pas sûr
que l'on bien rempli ces images elles
servent de pleuvent et les migrants ont
été livrés vivant aux pacers span amène
les clubs du golfe et narco trafiquants
qui contrôlent la région exige pleuvent
depuis la mort brutale de la jeune fille
belle un turbo wilbert notre guide
connaît bien l'équilibré délicat qui
conserve la paix dans ces territoires
ces groupes armés fixe parfois des
conditions et il s'agit de ne pas
dépasser les limites
même s'il ya toujours une marge de
manoeuvre
parfois ils décident des routes et des
sentiers que les passeurs doivent
utiliser cela se respecte
comme ça tout le monde travaille
d'airé tout cas pour le ghana nous nous
préparons à partir à nouveau un de loupe
des médias en afrique et la belge
pénible et mal la jungle pour tenter de
les rattraper dès l'autre côté de la
frontière
nous contournons la jungle ya la mer des
caraïbes
cédric est plus dispendieuse et plus
utilisés par les migrants les contrôles
migratoires se fait à aubel dia au
panama l'élu de ces petits villages sont
desserte la fermeture de la frontière a
limité les flots des migrants l'an
dernier
l'arrivée massive des migrants avaient
déclenchée une urgence sanitaire
[Applaudissements]
parsemer les longues du littoral désir
habité par deux membres du peuple qu'une
à leurs villages sont proches des sites
touristiques du panama c'est surtout
tonnes en plusieurs fois sauvé la vie
des migrants qui se sont égarés
c'est tout si palissy qu'est la mafia
chinoise fait passer ses clients qui
paie les groupies
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
après 10 heures de navigation nous
atteignons la côte du panama peu après
l'arrivée
il faut se soumettre le contrôle routier
toujours aucun signe du goût des millas
africain nous poursuivons dans ton
chemin vers l'est nord
[Musique]
passez aux cannoises une ville frontière
partagée par le panama et le costa rica
c'est une zone commerciale qui attire
des gens du pays
c'est aussi la porte d'entrée des
migrants en route vers l'amérique du
nord
[Musique]
les costa rica a ouvert dès qu'un pool
offrir une eau à 6 aux réfugiés
[Musique]
violence à la bia est officiellement
traductrice mais elle est beaucoup plus
que cela mais mais mais tu me vois
maintenant comme ça mais vraiment je
suis sale mais bt mons en salle il ya
des jours que je peux pas changer mes
vêtements mais celle de settat comme ça
même si tu me vois je suis plus après
prennent une douche avoir des vêtements
de nouveau ses différents moments je
sais je sais pas moi mais je suis pas
une mauvaise personne
vous voyez
cette gueule du nord du costa rica qui
nous trouvons des membres du groupe
d'africains qui ont traversé la jambe d
peine et de misère 15 jours 15 jours
dans les forêts il ya de gens il ya les
autres et famille qui vient tu vois pas
pas moi on arrête avec les mamans avec
les enfants moi je vis un autre fille de
35 ans mort devant nous et ensemble si
je savais que ça a été comme ça je ne
pouvais pas venir de se faire mais on
est et on est arrivés des ges et
qu'est-ce qu'on l'a fait faut continuer
roma roma responsbilité un homme délit
prix criaient aux autres de l'abandonner
y'avait pas continuer il y avait décidé
de cesser mourir je crois qui mord
conseillerais pas cette jungle à mon
pire ennemi c'est très dangereux
[Musique]
des journées et pouvoir ou ceux qui
s'occupent des migrants
les histoires laisse des marques
indélébiles et internationale
ils nous ont raconté comment trois
personnes d'origine indienne qui était
dans la jungle du derrien se sont fait
attaquer par des gens de la mafia qui
les ont poignardés c'est très difficile
pour nous au niveau émotionnel
parce qu'il raconte c'est avec beaucoup
de sentiments dans leur coeur il faut se
mettre à leur place c'est très triste de
les entendre raconter leur histoire est
de savoir que plusieurs de leurs amis
n'arrive jamais jusqu'ici que retourner
à la terre
à lui et au costa rica depuis presque
trois mois son égard de voile bien des
sentiments parfois contradictoires
qu'ils accompagnent les courages la peur
la douleur et la fois
une partie de son coeur est resté à tout
jamais dans le genre où il a listé ses
soeurs dans la rivière et avait personne
pour nous aider aussi avec elle qu'elle
pouvait bien là la rattrape et l'on ne
sait pas nager
et puis à des gros rochers dans
l'arrivée à la barre et on ne sait pas
nager on ne savait pas la rattraper et
elle est partie comme ça à 35 ans aline
appui souçonné les enfants dessin soir
quand on pense à elle ça nous donne ça
nous renforce on s'est dit on fait ça
pour elle en sa mémoire
si elle était là nous encourager mais
comme les conditions en afrique ne vont
pas changer de mai aline et les autres
migrants cd traversé la frontière avec
le nicaragua mais les pacers rendre la
tâche difficile
on nous dit bon voilà on peut vous aider
mais il ya des gens dépassés on arrive
ici j'ai tenté nous tarde à voir
toutefois déjà donné des armes et de
l'argent de 312 a330 300 dollars les
passeurs sont un nouveau protagoniste et
nous abandonner là il est parti
et puis l'autre devant disparaît le tdv6
barré
[Musique]
les nicaragua est devenue une étape
difficile à franchir
argent qui thomas chamakh et relais
tâche encore plus complexe
les familles en afrique n'ont plus les
moyens de les supporter les restes
canadien se transforment parfois un
cauchemar
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
après une année de moins prosep et goudé
ont repris la route et ont affronté la
jambe le new d'aliens un sortant de la
jambe
ils ont fait la route jusqu'au costa
rica c'est god et les manies des
recettes qui a documenté la suite du
voyage
après avoir contourné le nicaragua un
bateau la famille a traversé les
honduras ils sont ensuite franchi la
frontière wade mala puis ils ont
continué leur chemin vers le mexique
arrivé à la frontière ils sont traversé
la rivière sushis à petit à la raddho
il croit main
une ville de deux millions d'habitants
située face à san diego en californie
des milliers de migrants ont transité
par ces régions frontalières à la
poursuite de leur rêve une frontière non
seulement protégé par le mur mais aussi
par des patrouilles américaines qui font
les va et vient à longueur de journée
[Musique]
quatre mois après avoir quitté sao paulo
au brésil france était sa famille arrive
a dit quoi là
la maison d'amy gars au sud du mexique
leur a donné des nouveaux vêtements pour
la placer sous qu'il portait depuis les
débuts de ces voyages sont joints à nous
ne voulant pas aller à l'hôtel parce
qu'il fait économiser le prix qui nous
restons mais ne savons pas comment serré
la suite pour un hasard après avoir payé
les personnes et les transports l'argent
commence à manquer
[Musique]
et
de l'année la famille célesto la
curiosité est trop forte
ils se rendent à la frontière pour voir
ces murs qui séparent les états unis du
mexique
ce mur qui les sépare de leurs rêves
le couple profite aussi du moment pour
distraire sans fard pauline est marié et
souffrit de l'instant d'insouciance
recette ego des nouvelles à tout prix
éviter les postes frontaliers américains
de peur d'être déportés ils n'ont pas
les moyens de s'offrir les services d'un
passeur qui peuvent coûter jusqu'à
treize mille dollars merced ne perd pas
espoir avec godet et l'a décidé dès
bientôt partir pour moins volets rideaux
et traversé la frontière au texas
à cet endroit il n'y a pas de mur fossé
battre dans la vie
il faut souffert tous les moyens
possibles pour s'en sortir ce soit même
j'ai doublé tous les parcours tous les
doutes toutes les souffrances je les ai
oubliés
je veux maintenant les positivité ce
qu'ils aiment à réserver
[Musique]
bronchite n'a pas regretté son choix
la famille a réussi à traverser la
frontière illégalement à laredo au texas
sains et saufs après avoir été placé en
état d'arrestation
ils ont été relâchés
[Musique]
après plus de quatre mois sur la route
la faute et s'accumulent de jour la date
de la prochaine étape la ville de new
york puis celle des plaques ce beau des
là ils pourront prendre un taxi jusqu'à
la frontière canadienne
c'est sur la route vers place pour qui
nous avons rencontré adam un jeune
nigérian
en route vers le canada en afrique
adam est arrivé à new york un avion muni
d'un visa étudiant avant de quitter le
nigeria il avait la ferme intention de
se rendre au québec il nomine commencé à
apparaître quelques mots de passes et
ray comme ça bah ça va bien mais si je
m'appelais dire habite
bonne douche
bonsoir d'atrazine d'autonomie arrivé à
plaques ce tour à dan est accostée par
un chauffeur de taxi 1
les chauffeurs grand nombre des
campagnes qui s'arrête à la frontière
c'est ici qu'est la dame traverse
illégalement au canada
le polissoir à l'immigration qui fut
créé en syrie en 2007
[Musique]
rosette et ses enfants ont finalement
réussi à entrer au canada on vous dit
comment est on vous fait entrer dans
leur nouvelle vie tout c'est après cette
pause
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
après avoir parcouru le devenir km
course 7 est enfin arrivé à la fin de la
route des migrants quand je vois que je
suis venu ici donc je vois les miracles
et des dieux c'est courage c'est dieu
c'est pas moi
[Musique]
je suis content parce que je suis arrivé
il est entré par le chemin de russan en
centre de réfugiés de montréal est
devenu son premier foyer au pays
je logeais dans l'hôpital comme ça il y
avait les chambres d'hôtes à lowell
victoria il y avait l'espace pour nous
il y avait beaucoup d immigrants alors '
et il fallait régler une zone de la mer
de limitation elle sait bien que et ses
filles sont des survivantes qu'elles
peuvent maintenant tourner la page
si des films traces je vais passer toute
la vie ici parce que je l'aimé à fond
grandi ici
c'était le petit cancer un grand de 15
après dix mois mais pas l'idée de
l'afrique dans le wagon d'ici là et
c'est ici où on verrait si par contre
les routes a laissé des séquelles et pas
sur le match physique et psychologique
notre première préoccupation est d'abord
d'essayer de faire régner nos documents
parce qu'on venait du brésil jusqu'à
mexique on a environ des bancs des
apéros ou le document était perdue parce
qu'ils ont entre les sexes bonjour vous
dopez c'est qu'il pouvait prendre et
nous n'avons pas de doute là comme celle
ci et qui nous montre nous sommes deux
congolais et notre souci est d'abord de
faire et de voir comment est ce qu'on
doit faire rêver nos documents comme la
plupart des sujets qui arrivent au
canada la famille pu compter sur l'aide
des organismes qui travaillent pour que
les migrants ne répètent leur vie nous
est de nous dire comment faire l'avis
des migrations vous faut aller dans cet
organisme pour demander l'aide
il faut aller chercher l'avocat il faut
faire cela
montréal sa nouvelle vie est aussi belle
que dans ses rêves
jusque là il n'y encore nous sommes dans
les débuts au concombre tout en débutant
qui arrive dans de nouveaux pays
les débits et c'est toujours difficile
il faut d'abord chercher à s'organiser à
mettre des enfants à l'école et à
s'intégrer et dans le rythme est du pays
y voir comment ce que les pays marche
pour le marché de l'emploi chez des rats
privés d'emploi de plus à en découvre à
montréal la famille s'est trouvé un
appartement presque rêver n'importe quel
oh
je sais pas ce que c'est là qu'ils tour
cédant tôt on se connaît pas les vrais
ne se connaît pas chaque balle sort de
sa façon un autre l'important c'est que
nous avons un nombre pauvre vire de
recettes ne veux pas parler politique
il voudrait oublier les dangers tous
l'ont poussé à sortir de son pays et à
prendre autant de risques pour arriver
ici
elle veut surtout se tourner vers
l'avenir au québec ici à la liberté et à
la démocratie
c'est beau mais différemment chez nous
en afrique où il n'y a pas la démocratie
tout est désorganisé du point de vue
politique les gouvernements africains
tu ne sais pas bien géré les pays
grosse chute et son mari y ont trouvé un
emploi et ils ont abandonné l'aide
sociale leur fille pour telle école et
commence à bien parler français elle
commence à prendre sa famille demande
une chose qu'elle veut savoir en
français je vous explique en anglais aux
sessions c'est moi je ne connais pas je
connais pas d'enlever j'ai l'esprit que
ces annonces étaient ses enfants
marchent aujourd'hui sur le territoire
sécuritaire c'est ici que l'ère des
migrants les a amenés
c'est ici qu'il espère faire une
nouvelle vie
la route des migrants est en elle-même
un personnage à part entière bien
vivante en constante évolution
il réagit aux événements à
l'environnement et aux personnes qui ne
fréquentent difficile de calculer la
quantité des migrants sans papiers qui
ont traversé le continent américain du
sco canada puisqu'il s'est vite les
contrôles
rosette attend toujours que les
autorités canadiennes décide si elle et
sa famille selon accepté comme réfugiés
s'ils ont pressé sa demande elle sera
obligée de retourner au point de départ
seul le temps le dira
[Musique]
au nom de toute l'équipe on espère que
vous avez apprécié le reportage de ce
soir merci beaucoup d'avoir été là on se
retrouve la semaine prochaine pour une
autre enquête
[Musique]